To evaluate how accessible any app is,
you can step through the
Accessibility Testing Checklist.
Some of those steps will involve
changing the accessibility settings
in the setting's app.
The user will be able to choose
from these options.
We have TalkBack, Captions, Magnification,
increased font size, and more.
I want to point out one item
in particular, TalkBack service.
Blind and low vision users
can turn on the TalkBack service.
It allows them to navigate
around the device
with spoken feedback
as they interact
with each UI element on the screen.
There are slightly different gestures
for example to select,
or to focus on an item.
If it's the first time you turn it on,
there will be a tutorial
that you can step through.
When the user navigates
to these elements
TalkBack service will read aloud
the context description provided.
Every UI component that doesn't have
any visible text has a content description.
Using TalkBack or another
accessibility tool from the checklist,
open the Sunshine app,
find and fix at least one
accessibility issue in the app.
Then please share what you did
in the class discussion forum.